- All right, I always wanna
finish up with something
that might add some extra joy to your day.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
So today, it's got a little
personal connection as well.
Earlier this month I was
in Florida for an event
and I went into this little coffee shop
just, you know, to get some caffeine.
And it was really good.
And I ran into this woman
and discovered these amazing cookies.
Even more amazing, the
woman who made them.
We took a picture together
and we had a good time.
But she's proof that you can
actually reinvent yourself
at any time.
'Cause she started
discussing this new adventure
that she was on.
And I like a cookie, y'all.
So I was like, all right, I'll try one.
They were really good.
So we have her on the line
right now watching on WPTV
from Respect the Cookie,
say hi to Linda, everybody.
(audience applauds)
Hi, Linda.
So it's nice to see you again.
I loved your cookie.
I got in the car immediately
after leaving the coffee shop
and I was like, well
let's try this cookie.
It was incredible.
But I think what's cooler
is this cookie company
is part of a real kind
of change in your life
right now, right?
- Oh, absolutely, Kelly.
I moved from my longtime home
in Miami Beach, Florida
to West Palm Beach.
Along the way,
I've been making this
little cookie recipe of mine
and perfecting it.
And it came from my kitchen
so I call it From Linda's Kitchen.
And it's been an amazing journey for me.
- It's such a great cookie.
So tell us more about the cookies
and where people can get them.
- Oh, yes.
Well, I happened to bump into you
at that fun little coffee
shop in downtown West Palm,
which is called Subculture.
And the owner there invited me
because he fell in love with my cookies
and to help me get my start.
And I'm also on Instagram
@FromLindasKitchen.
So my hope is to scale and to get bigger.
So right now, it's just baby steps.
And those are some of my other concoctions
that I dreamt up along the way
because we were going into holiday season
and Valentine's Day.
And I just wanted to offer people more.
I'm a creative person
and I love, you know,
working with food products and color.
And there you saw all
those beautiful colors,
different cookies.
Right now just concentrating
on the chocolate chip cookie
because it's so rich.
And I double roll it.
That's why you get that burst of chocolate
in your mouth.
- Oh, my gosh.
- And it's an explosion.
And I'm so glad you liked it, Kelly.
- I loved it.
I wanted my friend that was with me-
And you gave her one.
I wanted her to not like
it and give it to me.
And unfortunately she
ended up liking it as well.
So just got the one. (laughs)
But it was so good.
But thank you, Linda.
I'm liking your post right now, all right.
(audience applauds)
- [Linda] Thank you, thank you so much.
- Absolutely, Linda, but that's not all.
Our season-long partner Pilot pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pin
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, ma'am.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience applauds)
- Oh my gosh, that's insane.
Thank you so much.
That's incredible.
- Absolutely.
- [Linda] Thank you.
- It was lovely seeing you again, Linda.
All the best.
Thank you to all our guests this hour,
Christina Ricci, Melissa Rauch,
the men of Channing
Tatum's "Magic Mike Live."
That was incredible.
Y'all have a great day and
if not, try and change it.